so today I'm going to talk to you about
some of my work
mobile interaction much of what this
work is conducted with my interns over
the past few years at Google first I
want to ask you this question how many
times do you access your mobile devices
per day so it turns out we access our
mobile devices quite a lot according to
the should this reporter from tpc be a
major adventure capital firm mobile
users are average use their smartphones
about 150 times per day these include
making phone calls messaging and the
other typical activities will be Jews
throughout the day so clearly mobile
devices have played a very important
role in our everyday life so it's
amazing how far computing technologies
have come along a typical smartphone
today today like Nexus 5 has more
computing power than the computer center
Apollo 11 to the moon but the way we can
leverage this anomalous computing power
is quite limited for a number of reasons
so if we think about the mobile user
interface today there are pretty much
structured based on graphical user
interface concepts such as windows and
menus these were introduced three
decades ago for desktop computers these
concepts are intuitive and easy to use
in a setting that has a large display
and the precise input devices such as a
mouse so big advantage of graphical user
interfaces is so called what do you see
is what you get the functionalities of
the system are actually exposed in
accessed through their graphical
representations
so a user can easily perform a target
action by acquiring the corresponding
graphical object but to the small form
factor of mobile devices really limits
the amount of information we can present
on the display and what we can possibly
acquire so the input bandwidth is a
further constrained by the lack of
precise input devices for example the
target item has to be large enough for
the finger to acquire right so as a
result the reach functionalities of the
system often have to be presented
through it deep hierarchy so navigating
this deep you a hierarchy requires a
significant amount of veera attention
and the very precise motor control so
these are not affordable for mobile user
so fundamentally traditional user
interfaces rely on the 2d coordinates of
the final touch point and the target
being acquired this so this paradigm is
the intuitive but it essentially ignores
the rich somatic so for user actions and
behaviors so these are potentially more
effective to evoke communicating what we
want to achieve so my research goal here
is to push the boundary of water a
computer system can possibly understand
about user actions and behaviors to
expand the interaction benefits of
mobile devices for the rest of the talk
I'm going to give you a few
examples of our work in this area so
first I'm going to show you how we can
use a hand draw symbols to access the
mobile devices I will talk about how
these gestures can carry rich
interaction cymatics and the compelling
interaction scenarios de Knable then I
will talk about the multi-touch input
the most important class of input
behaviors on mobile devices and I will
discuss the fundamental challenges
multi-touch input has raised to
interactive computing and how we can
address them using advanced the tools so
in addition to look at too explicit user
input it's important to expand the
interaction bandwidth this by learning
from user behaviors to optimize the UI
in the background for example by knowing
the user is a shopping in the grocery
store we can better adapt the
application for the user at that time so
at the beginning of the talk I asked you
how many times you access your mobile
devices per day so many of these
accesses actually require the user to to
turn on the screen unlock the phone and
navigate the DP or hierarchy so this
additional effort is imposed I'll every
task almost every target ask the user
wants to perform which are called habit
taxation or mobile access to address
these problems we developed the system
that allows the user to use gel to use
the gesture shortcuts to access the
mobile devices actually from the
by mode so here let's assume we want to
start the YouTube app on this phone
before we even turn on the screen we can
draw a letter Y directly on the
touchscreen sorry it's not so the system
will returns a list of search results
and then we can click on youtube so
that's how fast we can access our mobile
device such as the launching an app so
this is cool but as you have figured out
there are a few challenges to achieve
this functionality I'm going to talk
about our solutions to some of these
problems here so for this to work the
touch screen has to be always active in
sensing you user input so it's quite
possible that the user accidentally
touched the touch screen for example
when the phone sits in the pocket or
will one a hand extended a touch that
the better of the screen while holding
the device so the first problem we need
to address here is to be able to tell in
Canada gesture input from accidental
touches to do this we use tremendous
asset of Nexus 5 devices we ask the
participants to use these devices as
their primary device for for few days
and we observed on average each user
generated about 800 accidental touches
so that's a lot right more than what we
would expect then we also asked the same
group of people to draw character
gestures a variety of conditions such as
using the form a single handedly Oh pi
PI manually walking versus sitting in
all these a
conditions so based on this data we're
trying to understand how intended
gesturing input is actually different
from accidental touches by a look at the
signals from multiple sensors such as
the touchscreen the the proximity sensor
and the accelerometer here I want to
give you a couple of examples about
these analysis so both extend the touch
and the intended the gesture input
generate a sequence of points 0 which we
call a gesture is so which we call it a
touch stroke right the heat maps here
show how touch strokes are actually
distributed on the screen as we can see
here accidental touches this are
distributed almost the uniformly on
screen but the intended gestures are
more concentrated at the central screen
so this is because accidental touches
are they are crude mole rent or more
randomly but before you are four in ten
in the gestures the user the user tend
to choose the center area of the screen
for maximum for maximum flexibility just
to clarify here we use the farthest
point on the stroke to the battles as
the location of the stroke so the
character so the difference of these two
type of behaviors is also well captured
by other sensors such as the
accelerometer as we can see here the
acceleration chain change for intended
gestures is actually quite small it's
because the user tries to keep the
device very stable for joining the
gesture but the for extended touches
that is not the case so based on this
analysis we trained a decision tree
model by come combining a set of
features we achieved the good accuracy
in terms of procedure in the recall here
I want to show you how well it actually
works so these extended touches will not
trigger any actions but when the user
draw the gesture the system response the
right away that's how it works so
because now we need to sense the user
input all the time a battery consumption
became a very important problem our
current implementation is only last fall
day because we need to keep this cpu
running of the time for continuous
sensor processing but several model
modern smartphones have already adopted
the the architecture of using a
low-power DSP chip to process continuous
sensory input without waking up the CD
you but it's hard for us to access these
coprocessors so to find out how the
battery consumption of our system in
such an architecture we used an external
approach by experimenting with our
gesture detection code on this low-power
DSP chip it's the same chip that has
been used by iPhone the power so the
experiments indicated that the battery
consumption of our system is quite small
right so both of the high detection
accuracy and the trivial battery
consumption indicate data is always on
gesture approach is a visa
so so far I have talked about how we can
detect the intended gesture input so
once a gesture is the detected do we
need to infer the target item the user
wants to access so there are multiple
levels of ambiguity in this process the
system can miss recognize the gesture or
the user can mrs. spell the keyword of
the target on top of these it's often
ambiguous which target the user wants to
access giving a character for example
leather why could it be four for a
different target rather than YouTube so
this process is achieved by a sister
subsystem named gesture search it
addresses all these ambiguities both on
the UI and in the underlying algorithm
I'm going to talk about this system a
little bit so just research allows a
user to access a range of targets such
as the applications contacts and
settings using gesture shortcuts
alfanumérico gestures here let's assume
we want to turn on Wi-Fi hotspot right
that's a task some of you probably do so
well we can draw the gesture and we're
on screen so this design allows I free
input as we can see here the gesture
here looks like a lighter a or letter H
right it's a ambiguous to the system so
the system actually preserved this
ambiguity by returning the search
results that match either of these
interpretations at the same time you can
probably see that the original gesture
is the show
at the bottom of the screen this
indicates that the interpretation of the
gesture is not determined yet right so
at this point we can screw the list to
find the target or we can draw more
gestures to ask the system to refine
search results with these two gestures
are the target tethering & portable
hotspot is shown at the second position
now we can click on it and come
configure the hotspot so internally we
use the single population model to
capture all these levels of ambiguity it
encodes how input gestures can lead to
different targets every time the user
interacts with the system it alerts from
it alerts from the user behave you and
by updating the public of probability
distribution in the model so just
research is a available on Google Play
and as we can see here users responded
positively to the system I encourage you
to try it out yeah so in addition to
being a useful tool we also observed
some profound changes regarding user
behaviors as this user commented I
forgot to use menu after you install
ASAP so we really see the transition
from the use of graphical user
interfaces to gesture-based interaction
now that you another user commented i
gestured i find it also chosen to
you didn't try to pick up another gel in
the wife as soon as i unlock my device
you could have automatically like ever
could just show a keyboard and i could
just start typing there it becomes a
spotlight search over my phone just like
you did is there anything that was
particularly to wire drawn gesture which
has potentially say more like my
ambiguity to it then something that's
like a form factor that they're used to
look like the on-screen keyboard so is a
question with uh um I mean you turn you
on the screen I locker the fun part
always with how you would do I mean the
choice between keyboard and gesture you
could imagine I assume a button and what
happens is a keyboard pops up so there's
no unlock screen it's just the unlock
screen is a keyboard where I start
typing what I want with a spotlight
search and then that becomes the washer
like that's all over them remember use
this about having quick access to a
launcher or is it about the gestures
themselves as the input modality that's
really I think it has to do with a post
part so the further the first part is
the difference between keyboard based
interaction and the gesture based
interaction so gesture-based interaction
a gesture input has the advantage of or
you don't need to acquire small targets
on display so basically the entire
screen is what you can use rather than a
small target side so another thing here
is there is a tourney on the screen and
the unlock the phone these are
additional steps we're trying to be
trying to save we try to avoid yeah i
think the there are really two problems
we try to address why is to determine if
the user wants to interact with the
device once that's determined then we
need to figure out what the user wants
to do with the device
that's the second part I think this has
the advantage compared to the
traditional route but any other
questions I can't even use my phone a
slide-out keyboard or depending on that
if I'm using my deaf devices are
teaching people on this that the app
currently allowed for recognizing a key
press on physical keyboard as and
interpreting that as if it was a major
investor and certainly sir that brand
I'm not sure I understand the Mayo I'll
part of the question but if you wanted a
physical keyboard on my way connected by
linking um currently it's already set up
in android OS that problem i press the
key on that keyboard will turn on the
lights does gesture search grab the
input from this keyboard and turn that
into the cervical search as well or does
they only listen to the screening yeah
so the technocore it only takes a touch
screen put right now yeah but that's the
interesting thought actually a why
project I did with my interest to enable
gestures on the keyboard even right so
if you slide your finger or the key on a
physical keyboard oh we can also do
gestures that way so i think it's not
exactly what you are asking but as kind
of related
instead a lot warmer I know I feel ya
when you're up to it your search squared
how can you distinguish like sliding
slowly move down the list hundred yeah
that's a good question i escaped that
part because i didn't want to go go into
too much detail so basically you're
right so there are two type of the
behaviors why is it use you can screw
the list the otherwise you can draw
gestures directly on top of the list so
currently we're trying to differentiate
what you're trying to do based on the
trajectory of the gesture so if you at
the beginning when you slide when you
when you slide your finger on the screen
it's really ambiguous to the system what
you're trying to do but they're trying
to make a decision as you slide your
finger more so simple speaking if you're
moving your finger up and down in my
interpreted as schooling but i mean if
there's no more variation on the on the
trajectory idiom i interpreted as a
gesture so there's other more details is
actually in the paper
okay you could also have it you can have
a very short list so there's no scoring
name well yes so that's actually quite
reasonable so another layout we had at
one point on tablet is it's a great
layout you don't screw the grid so you
can there's no such problem anymore yep
here so this light actually partially
answers your question I mean I mean
justifies your idea about to having
fewer items on the screen so basically
based on the large-scale data said I
collected from millions of users we can
better understand user behaviors and the
performance with the system so here I
want to talk about a couple of these
analysis as you can see here the
position the user tends to click on a
base the typical power law distribution
right with the top addition according
for over sixty percent of traffic so
come back to a question we can probably
just present six targets of seven
targets on screen that will probably be
enough right so in general the more
gestures the user used for access or in
other words the longer queries the more
likely a target will appear at the top
of polishing the list so on average it
took about less than two gestures are
for the user to get to a target so so
it's about a couple of strokes away so
that's quite as a compelling and just
research currently only use the top item
for the prediction based on user
behaviors about 46
% of the traffic was actually completed
by the prediction based on user
behaviors position is one suggests that
what's happening is I keep I keep
gesturing until then I want us at the
top even if it might exist but it's
lower exactly okay so that's not a part
in interesting ways we we basically see
two types of behaviors Oh some users
tend to draw more gestures to bring
their targeted to the top position right
so even the patio the target is actually
like a third or fourth position they
don't want to click out you want to draw
more dressers to bring the target
without competition but some users it
turns its crew list they just drawn what
gesture then trying to they trying to
find it the target in the list what's in
the majority of the users trying to draw
more gestures do to access target as a
one user commented I don't care how many
gestures on how to draw my target it
will eventually show up at the top right
so sometime the time it takes is not the
only important matter here so it's about
the dedicated attention you have to pay
to the interaction I think that's
something yeah so at this point you
might be wondering if we can actually go
beyond just the character gestures how
about a plus sign for Google+ or the
crispy writing of my for Europe times so
to support is the arbitrary symbols for
for gesture shortcuts a one approach is
that we can assign a specific symbol for
each of these targets yend events then
we can compare and no gesture with these
templates based on how similar they are
right so we can find the one that
matches the best so my colleagues thing
I developed a few errands for just a for
template-based the recognition so some
of these have been used by a lot of
researchers in the field for their
simplicity but one big problem with this
kind of approach is that you have to
define all the shortcuts year in advance
right so it's non-trivial Eifert of all
for the user to define and memorize
these shortcuts then we ask the question
if we can univer the meaning of an
arbitrary gesture without having the
user to actually define these gestures
so it sounds like mission impossible
right so but I want to test this with
you can you guess the meaning of this
gesture what the user tries to activate
so you didn't see my talk before right
cool okay one more test how about this
one so the fact that you can guess the
meaning of these gestures does tell us
something right I will come back to this
later so then we to find out how users
actually derive or perceived easy
gesture shortcuts we did a study with
the 26 participants we ask we ask them
to come up with a gesture shortcuts for
about 400 targets you move in whatever
way did they think appropriate so these
are some examples from this study from
this the open ends study I want to talk
about some important results from this
study so first we see basically makes a
character and enjoying based gestures
right with the drawing so the
characteristic gestures being the
dominant form so this
explains why gesture search actually
works right so it's using often
numerical gestures another important
result here is that we fund quite a bit
of a commonality across the gesture
shortcuts people define for different
targets so in this experiment we're
trying to recognize why users gesture
shortcuts using those have been defined
by other other participants so as you
can see here we we got some accuracy
here and the accuracy could be even
better if we had more participants so
it's quite sparse actually are in terms
of the number of gestures we got for
each target I trained on a random other
users gesture I would still get the
right thing twenty percent of the time
so where are those participants or
ensure their we use the template based
the recognition by using 25 participants
data as a training samples we try to
predict this last users gestures right
well but all this all this data is
collected separately right so yeah so
this kind of explains why you were able
to guess the meaning of the gestures of
those two only two examples i just
showed earlier right so based on these
discoveries from this open-ended the
study we design the system to universal
meaning of arbitrary gesture the user
drawers right so it combines a crucible
Hanratty recognizer and the similarity
based on matching so for each unknown
gesture it asked the curse of the
Highland rightly recognized you to
recognize it it's using a language model
that is a dynamic
constructed based on the data on the
device at the same time the unknown
gesture is matched against the gestures
that have been used by the user and
other users like that's the crowd so if
the target if the intended target is not
in the matches returned by the system
the user has to manually undefined
target but every time the user interact
with with the system it alerts from the
user behavior so it gets smarter and
smarter so collectively there's no magic
but to each individual user some time
and it works like a magic right it can
guess the meaning of the gesture without
you to tell the system what the gesture
is ok I guess I forgot to show these so
basically this party is the it's the
crowd powered recognition the other
party is this party ups this party is
the curse behind right here recognition
so this is a quick a quick demo about
how well the system works as you can see
here you can draw a cursive handwriting
this arbitrary symbol
okay any questions super though like I
can imagine that drawing atheists
probably faster than trying a perk right
um like how much like more useful as
this that over just like drawing or some
convention like just the cursive
handwriting yeah I think you're asking
about another metric that is how
efficient it is from the articulation
point of view I think that's certainly
one factor but another thing here is a
learn learn ability and how naturally
days to the user but just to your
question yeah I think you're right
sometime often America gestures will be
much easier to go other than graphical
gestures but the point of this work is
that we want to make sense of whatever
the user drawers right so this is just
the based on like Tony some participants
imagine when we reach some critical mass
we can make sense of many things right
cool so this diagram here shows all the
amount of contribution each prediction
sauce had as we can see here initially
matching I know just sure with the crowd
gestures and the cursive handwriting
recognition played a very important role
as the system sees more the more
gestures from the specific user matching
with the user's own gesture are
gradually became the most important
prediction source so what is important
here is that at the very beginning of
the experiment before the system has
observed any usage from the user it was
able to guess the meaning of the gesture
seventy-seven percent of the time right
so it's significantly reduce they use
the year
user effort and the bootstraps the
performance of the system so we took
this crowd sourcing power the
recognition further by developing a
general platform for generating
recognition techniques briefly the idea
is that the developer can describe a
recognition task in this platform called
crowd learner in the dentist's trip it's
a recognition task to mobile workers so
as the data comes in our learner
continuously change the recognizer
whenever the recognition accuracy falls
below a threshold so the companion
result we got from this work is that a
developer together a usable recognizer
such as the one for recognizing hand
drawn symbols with less than ten dollars
and the under two hours yes yes so no
reason so next I'm going to talk about
multi-touch input probably is the most
important class of input behaviors are
mobile devices so it's amazing how many
multi-touch gestures are actually enable
the ear mobile applications such as Maps
so these gestures are intuitive and
efficient to use but they're very
difficult to program manually so when it
comes to interactive computing there are
always two important problems to to
address once two unidentified the target
object the user wants to
the others to determine the operation
the user intended for the for the object
for traditional graphical user
interfaces these can be easily achieved
with the precise input device such as a
mouse and a set of well-defined the
interaction events such as the clicks
and drag-and-drop but for multi-touch
DUIs it's often quite tricky to address
these issues for example when we land
our fingers on the screen it's often
ambiguous to the system which object we
try to manipulate for example as we can
see here one of the fingers actually
partially landed on the cameras
underneath the photo so another factor
here is that a comp so rich interaction
semantics of multi-touch gestures are
often expressed through complex fingered
foundations and the continuous motion
it's hard for developers to program them
right in there a code and lastly so mod
is a one big advantage of multi-touch
input is that a user can perform
multiple actions at the same time but
it's hard to for the developers to
manage these parallel operations based
on the traditional event processing
framework
I mean if these are all true independent
objects than theirs firing off
independent listeners was what is this
difficult so basically you you have to
dispatch events two different actions
yes so thank you I think you can you can
certainly good but it's going to be
complicated for you to manage the whole
the events and because each of these
actions will have its own state right so
they often resulting a complex state
transition diagram I would buy it if
maybe I'm misunderstanding i buy this if
there are relations between multiple
things that are happening so you know
imagine on a traditional desktop
computer if I if I attach using jQuery
or something a drag event over here in a
drag event over there you know they
could in theory all the Java scripts
typically single-threaded they could in
theory just sort of run in separate
threads and react to the to the drag
events individually but it seems like
maybe what you're getting at is that
it's difficult if I'm like enough if I
need some behavior that involves
dragging these two together to create a
pile or something like this we're like
now you have these independent listeners
that have to trigger some some joint
inference is that what you're getting it
I think so the cigarette here is that if
we dispatch events deterministically
like what you described then it becomes
to your two independent problems that
it's much easier right so what's
complicated here is that for monitoring
inputted the dispatching of the events
often is not deterministic like so the
events for war so there's some chance
that the event for one action it might
be active or different action I think
it's more to do with a event dispatching
part but I think you're right when
there's the interaction between two
behaviors it becomes complicated going
on
or continues to advance so to address
these problems are we my interns I have
a have been developing advanced tools
for developers to easily program
multi-touch into a multi-touch input
inner applications we want to transfer
what programmers have learned from
programming gooeys to multi touch
interaction so next of all I want to
show you how this to actually works here
let's assume we want to end some
multi-touch behaviors to our to this
photo album application so we started by
ending a gesture library to the project
this is a typical Android you clip set
up so this will bring up our gesture
creation tool we can directly
demonstrate the toilet travel gestures
these common gestures can be recognized
by by the system and automatically added
it to the gesture set that's the top
left of the screen so if you all we need
are these the common gestures Oh in less
than 20 seconds we have accrued at our
gesture set but what if we want a new
gesture something has never be seen by
the system like this three finger pinch
is recognized as a three-finger swipe
now the developer can give it the right
name three-finger pinch or pinto with
three fingers the system alerts from
that gesture from now on it can
correctly recognized three-finger pinch
so that's how we can add a new gesture
to the set
so the gesture set has a XML
specification automatically generated
here we can find it here each gesture
for example we can specify the temporal
and spatial constraints for these
gestures such as the time interval
between two are two tabs for double tap
revenge a question so once the gesture
set is created it's a available to the
project as a type of a resource just
like layouts and images we can directly
reference we can treat these gestures as
a high-level events and reference their
names in the code so our touch framework
is designed in a way that it can be
easily integrated with the existing
event framework as you can see here we
can attach a gesture event have a
handler to any object we want to have a
gesture behaviors it's very similar to
actually how we program a GUI
interaction with these we have added a
set of multi-touch gestures to our
application we can perform all kinds of
multi-touch behaviors so we come on
manipulate the photo and the underlying
cameras
can transition from one behavior to
another without lifting all the fingers
so we can also create a photo group by
selecting a collection photos we can
then manipulate the collection at the
hole on each individual photo we are
within the group remains interactive
so all these the behaviors can be easily
er implemented with this tool with the
system ugh actually handles the
complexity underneath so we asked the
eighth professional programmers have
questioned evolution Kapoor doesn't
handle the challenge presented before
where you coaching to try to do two
different gestures simultaneously and
handle both each other rotate one
picture while moving another one wait oh
yes so it tries to so that's so it
basically as the slides I'm going to
cover later on basically it has a model
to to capture parallel operations yes
but it's not showing you in that video
so we asked the ages of professional
programmers who had a angel experience
to use the two to enable multitouch
behaviors for an application on average
it took them less than took them about
20 minutes to finish the task we also
compared this composer our condition
with the baseline condition when our two
was not available then none of the
participants could actually finish the
task so this comment was made by one of
their are one with the participants when
this when he suddenly realized the
complex event tri-nations they have to
cover in the code which is not something
they could finish in the time allow the
unit experiment come off
so now I want you to talk a little bit
about the important technical details
underlying this tool as I mentioned
earlier there are two important factors
we want to cover we want to address why
is the target interface object the other
is a the intended operation or gesture
here so we use the two random variables
to capture these two quantities for
probabilistic inference the dependency
between these two variables here
captures the semantics that an interface
object determines what kind of gesture
behaviors should be available so then we
design our model based on a dynamic
beings network that universe the current
interface object and gesture from a
sequence of ron touch events so the part
of the model captures the semantics out
how well the observer touch events
actually match a given object and
gesture for example how well the touch
event found seeing the boundary of the
object and how well the continuous
motion with touch events demo Street the
the the transformation required by
gesture such as scaling for the pinch
gesture so the other part of model is
about how the past the interaction state
actually influences the current state
right for example for TT 0 for single
tap revenge we expect the finger the to
be lived after the finger goes down
so the model seems quite completely in
terms of capturing all these factors
that determine the interaction state I'm
going to talk a little bit about how we
can create such a model right so there
are two stages when we create a gesture
set the system automatically generates a
inverse model for each individual
gesture either based on the
demonstration or the XML specification
then depending on how these gestures are
actually allocated to interface objects
at the runtime the system instantiates
and assembled is the individual universe
model to form a global model so here
this plot shows how well the system can
recognize a set of four multi-touch
gestures as we can see here the more
touch movements the system sees it can
better recognize these gestures but with
the multi-touch interaction we also want
to make the students as early as
possible right so we don't want to which
the entire gesture is finished then we
decide what is the user is actually
doing so as you can see here the number
of gestures in the said they actually
tell us something about how how hard it
is to separate these gestures but we
want to develop a more precise measure
about ambiguity with gesture set any
questions so far
so we develop the measure about the
ambiguity of a gesture set um by look at
how the inference model of each
individual multi-touch gesture is
different from each other in the set I'm
not going to talk about the matter here
but the scatterplot here shows the
effectiveness of our measure as you can
see here exactly the this ambiguity I
put a big you to hear it's really
designed figured so that this ambiguity
here is negatively correlated with the
amount of touch events the system has to
observe of to reach a target accuracy
like ninety percent correct so what we
can get from this is here is that we can
learn a linear predictor to tell us how
much touch a movement will be needed to
reach certain accuracy this try this
actually translates to how quickly the
system kind of resolve the ambiguity and
the response to the user input so so far
I have talked about interaction
modalities in the foreground it's
equally important for us to learn from
user behaviors to leverage the context
are inputted to optimize the UI so for
this I'm going to talk very briefly
about my recent work on mobile event
prediction so predictions are useful in
many cases for example we can reduce the
clutter of the home screen by only
presenting applications that a user is
likely to launch next likewise we can we
can predict to color contacts for speed
dial and the dish options for
based on the user's past behaviors but
the curse of the current partner here is
that developers often need to develop
prediction components for each of these
applications right so the involved lot
of technical expertise such as a machine
learning and the introduces a repetitive
engineering effort and the with mobile
computing resources so more importantly
these isolated prediction models can
only see the user behavior that happens
within the application while interaction
behavior often so an interaction
behavior often has something to do
something to do beyond a single
application right so it's often situated
in your much larger context so to
address the these problems I took a
infrastructure based approach by
developing our device prediction service
it learns from the interaction events as
reported by each application and the
predicts what the user is going to do I
mean what actions the user going to do
for you for each application so
internally the service lenser the learns
of prediction model for each application
by combining a set of well-defined
features using an online learning
framework so so all these prediction
models are not isolated so they actually
take into account how the behavior in
one application is related to the
behaviors in other applications the
experiment I did by evaluating the
service with two large-scale data sets
indicated that using the cross app
behaviors can significantly improve the
prediction accuracy so that's all what I
want to talk about it for this work
shouldn't that you're tracking going to
smoke machine are they generic actions
that are registered across the entire
device or they ate or do the
applications themselves publish events
that would be specific to the
application like in the speed dial app
maybe there's like a contact selected
event that gets that's observable sure
also all these are application specific
events SDK that makes these events
observable to you oh that's a good
question so the programming paradigm
here is that it's up to the application
to report what has actually happened the
in application you then they send a API
so you're you're at least here exactly
so in a sense of impaction events of
interest to the service in the later on
I can actually query Oh what the user is
going to do at this point okay so so far
all the examples I have a given to you
is regarding a single device but as
mobile in a variable computer gadgets
actually become ubiquitous and diverse
it's quite a common for user to perform
a task across a range of devices so I
want to give you two examples of what we
have been doing on the cross device into
action the mobile devices would become
very powerful there are small form
factor means that collaborating or
sharing information with someone else is
a turn-based experience we present open
project a highly scalable web based
framework for sharing mobile application
on a remote display using an intuitive
projection metaphor with only the phones
camp let's say Ben wants to show Angela
a photo to project the image gallery app
been aimed the phone's camera had a QR
code that identifies a display once
identified the QR code turns into a
checkerboard pattern tooth checkerboard
automatically moves to follow the
phone's motion emulating a projector
based solution Ben can also scale up his
projection by gesturing in a
counterclockwise fashion once ben is
satisfied he canna fix the projection
and put the phone away at this point Ben
and Angela can flip through the photos
either on the phone or even on the touch
enabled display and their change will be
shown in real time open project allows
users to collaborate around larger
surfaces and Tacitus sharing media or
navigation task a touch enabled remote
display even enables physical
multiplayer mobile the gaming everything
runs natively on the phone but its
projected on any display that can run a
browser window additionally open project
needs no external hardware to simulate a
hardhead projector our bus tracking
algorithm uses a single marker to track
a user's motion with only the built-in
camera open project was designed to be
easily deployed a large number of low
powered mobile devices animal displays
Android developers can enable remote
sharing of their applications by adding
our lightweight library which performs
all the work locally on the mobile
device moreover our web library enables
streaming of multiple mobile devices
screens on any number of displays
without performing any complex
computation combined the architecture
provides a highly scalable solution that
eliminates the need for complex fiber
powering servers and remote displays we
evaluated open project through a number
cards maybe there's a framework for
developers to create cross device where
action so any questions for the first
video ok just show the last night
encrypting developers can program and
test
cross-device behaviors using weeds
web-based integrated authoring
environment here a developer creates a
new service and edits it in the Edit
panel the developer selects a device
with a shareable display in the script
leaves abstractions allow developers to
focus on their target interaction
behaviors regarding the devices
capabilities and affordances in the
layout panel the developer adds an image
element in HTML and specifies to show it
on this device the developer then
chooses another device with a small
touch display and adds two buttons to it
for photo navigation by adding a
callback function to event tap colon
button the script now allows the user to
go forward and backward through the
image list on the other display the
developer tests the interaction with the
emulators when ready the developer adds
real devices to the weave Network for
live testing the developer deploys the
scripts to weaves runtime environment on
an ad-hoc network of devices with
minimal effort we've creates a range of
rich cross-device behaviors by adding
just a few more lines of code the
developer enables a new interaction mode
of swiping on smart eyewear
here are some more use cases with this
script a launch pad on a wearable device
launches native applications on the
phone the all mode invokes a callback
function when a specific event occurs on
all of the selected devices at the same
time for example this script enables
multiple users to join a group by
physically shaking their devices at the
same time the combined operator combines
several event types for multiple devices
here across device pinch gesture is
detected to zoom in on a photo alright
so lastly I want to thank the interest
who have worked with me over the past
few years I only got the chance to show
some of our projects if you want to know
more about our work come to visit my
website thanks for sort of any any
questions you've been holding on to or
open in the discussion
something about the talking about have
you thought about the closed loop into
that so walk into the supermarket and
knows where you are so then goes and
brings us information that's relevant so
are you talk about the application
scenario like before we know you know
location specific information or
reconfiguring the device in such a way
yeah I think so a lot of work a lot of
work has has been done in the field of
for location-based all location has the
interaction location-based interaction
so I think that's the typical scenario
actually people often use like if you go
somewhere that the application should we
bring up for location specific
information so yeah I think that would
be a good example but i'm not sure if i
have as a realization answered my
question and not all of it has anyone
looked at emotion ap configuration so if
the computer the computer to go and be
either state yeah actually that's cool
porn so I think a lot of work actually
is going on in that regard I think there
are all these sensors try to detect your
emotions stress neighs anxiety but so
far a lot of applications are focused on
health related things but too I think by
knowing all these things oh we can
certainly improve interactions in
in some way right so but to not many
applications I mean beyond the house are
actually out there I haven't seen any
you